[Music]
this week on Q&A historian Adam Hoch
shield he discusses his book Spain in
our hearts Americans in the Spanish
Civil War 1936 to 1939
[Music]
Adam Hoch show the title of your new
book is Spain in our hearts what's that
title mean it comes from a quotation
from Albert Camus which I ought to know
by heart by now but I don't but he said
it in 1945 after the Spanish Civil War
had ended and it goes something like
this men of my generation have always
had Spain in our hearts because there we
learned that you could be right and
still be defeated that courage was not
its own reward and it goes on like that
how many Americans fought in the Spanish
Civil War
roughly 2800 American volunteers went
there they were among the 35 to 40
thousand volunteers from over 50
countries and of those 2,800 Americans
who went to Spain 750 did not come back
and that's actually a higher death toll
percentage-wise than the US military had
in either of the world wars what were
the years of the Spanish Civil War and
why was it fought it began very suddenly
taking the world by surprise in July of
1936 and it lasted until the beginning
of April 1939 so almost three years it
was an extraordinarily bloody and brutal
conflict and essentially here's why it
began Spain for many centuries had
essentially been a monarchy in more
recent times 1920s that had been mixed
with a period of military dictatorship
in 1931 the King left the country they
held elections and it became a republic
the Spanish Republic and people all over
the world rejoiced that a country that
had experienced very little democracy at
last seemed to be getting it and there
were great hopes for a reform
but it was a land of vast inequalities
between rich and poor small number of
landowners had these huge estates
mindand and millions of peasants had
little or no land in 1936 a coalition of
liberal and left-wing parties won the
elections this was absolute anathema to
the powerful right-wing forces in Spain
and in July 1936 a large group of
right-wing army officers staged a revolt
against the elected government of the
Spanish Republic and this was the
beginning of the Spanish Civil War how
many people lived in Spain back in 1936
I believe it was roughly 23 million
something I may be off by a million or
two but it was something on that order
who what kind of a group was in the
leadership then well the elected
leadership of the Spanish Republic were
people from parties that would be
considered Democratic Socialist Liberal
Democrats elsewhere in West in Western
Europe they were were at that time a
small number of Spanish communists in
the national legislature not very many
the generals who led this right-wing
revolt from whom a very tough talking
young general named Francisco Franco was
very quickly emerged as the leader and
the dominant figure they represented a
much older Spain they wanted to restore
a Spain where the large landowners and
big industrialists would be dominant
where there would be absolutely no
trappings of democracy at all no Free
Press a military dictatorship do away
with elections do away with any kind of
land reform and hand education in the
country back to the Catholic Church
because in the secularization process
that had begun a few years before they'd
begun to take education out of the hands
of the church
the Catholic Church in Spain was by far
the most reactionary in Europe and you
know the the Spanish nationalist says
the army officer rebels called
themselves believed that co-education
was a conspiracy from the devil and the
you know men and women should be
segregated in education education for
women under their rule and the rule of
the church that they gave it back to was
education for women was very strong on
sewing and religion and not much else so
there were really two diametrically
opposed views of what kind of country
they wanted Spain to be want to show
some video of Francisco Franco he won as
you pointed out in your book how long
was he the head of Spain he won the war
in early 1939 and remained dictator of
the country wielding close to absolute
power of life and death for the
remainder of his life which was 36 years
he died only in 1975 amid signs of
senility and ruled with an iron fist
right up to the end torture was routined
right to the very end no elections no
free trade unions no Free Press let's
look at a little bit of what he sounded
like and looked like
what's the worst thing he did there is
people well I think you can sort of see
it in that clip right there he's
essentially saying everybody must be
United and essentially expressed the
popular will this way which means
essentially do what I say and I think
the worst thing that he did was to
extinguish any kind of expression of
democratic feelings whether through
dissent in the press whether through the
existence of civic organizations whether
through any kind of elections whatever
for example participation in anything
that had the trappings of belonging to
an international organization even if
for something very non-political you
know you belong to a group of Esperanto
speakers or you were active in a
Montessori School or in the Rotary Club
all of these things were forbidden
because they were international non
Spanish organizations it was he really
did Institute a kind of totalitarian
rule that was not dissimilar to other
forms of totalitarian rule in the Soviet
Union and Nazi Germany and fascist Italy
it was somewhat different from the
others in that the Catholic Church had
such a huge role in it but it was a kind
of totalitarianism so if you're out
watching this and you're an American and
you really don't care about Spain what
what relationship does your book have to
the American people
well if we roll black back the drift we
roll back the clock to the mid-1930s
one of the things that was on the minds
of a lot of good people all over the
world was this ominous sense that
fascism was on the rise in Europe
Hitler had come to power in Germany in
1933 Mussolini had already been in power
since the 1920s in Italy in 1935
Mussolini had gone and conquered himself
a colony in Ethiopia a war which finally
came to an end in 1936 so it was clear
that you know fascism was expanding
there Hitler was making all sorts of
noises about wanting to expand to the
east you know grabbing territory in
Eastern Europe and Russia that
rightfully somehow should be under
German domination the Soviet Union was a
grim place but not as many details were
known in the West as have been become
known subsequently and they were not
talking about expanding so the Menace
seemed to be expanding fascism in Europe
and when this coup attempt happened in
Spain when all over the country
right-wing army officers tried to seize
power and in parts of the country
succeeded in seizing power in 1936 it
sent a shock wave of alarm throughout
the world because here was a major
country in Europe the right-wing
military quickly backed by Hitler and
Mussolini who sent arms airplanes pilots
tanks tank drivers and Mussolini
eventually sent 80,000 ground troops
here was the Spanish right making a grab
for power and people all over the world
felt it ought to be resistant if not
here where otherwise we're next Franklin
Delano Roosevelt was president what was
his position toward the idea of
supporting the Republic of Spain
well Roosevelt was definitely a small
d-- democratic-- well as a large d
democrat and certainly somebody who was
personally very
opposed to fascism however he was very
wary of getting drawn into the Spanish
Civil War in any way he knew that the
American people at this point were
deeply isolationist and that any kind of
opinion poll that you looked at and
Roosevelt was a great reader of opinion
polls would tell you that people did not
want to get drawn into another war in
Europe in any way he knew this it's also
believed that we've never been able to
find the exact evidence it was probably
never put down on paper it's believed
that he promised the hierarchy of the
American Catholic Church that before the
1936 campaign for reelection that he
would not intervene in Spain the the
Catholic Church all over the world
heavily backed the revolt by General
Franco and his allies because it was a
matter of restoring the church to power
in Spain and in fact Spaniards on the
other side were so anti-clerical that
they had actually murdered thousands of
priests and monks and so on so it's
believed that Roosevelt made that
promise to Catholic Church in any event
throughout the war he decided to keep
America neutral not to make any attempt
to evade the fairly strict US neutrality
laws that were there in place and not to
prosecute a major oil company that
actually did evade those laws you write
in your book that had the 2800 Americans
that participated in war that two-thirds
of them were Jews that's an estimate I'm
not sure I use the figure of 2/3 but
people believe that anywhere from 1/3 to
1/2 may have been Jewish it's very hard
to pin down because so many Jews
American Jews changed their names the
reason I ask you that is why what what
what's the reason that they participated
a much higher rate than the percentage
of Jews in America well to quote one
volunteer who went to Spain more Ricola
from New York he said for us it was
never about Franco it was always about
Hitler American Jews like Jews all over
the world saw Hitler on the horizon they
saw the things he was saying about Jews
it fueled recruitment of volunteers to
fight in Spain not just in this country
but in many many countries as well
American Jews were also always
disproportionately represented
represented in organizations of the left
and that was another thing that drew
them to Spain you've written actually
since this book was published about a
man named del Berg del Berg died at age
100 on February the 28th of this year
here's some video this was from back
2013 the last living member I believe of
the 2,800 Americans had fought in Spain
I was very affected by the fascist
attempt to take over in Spain I couldn't
tell you why I just didn't like the idea
and that was my political understanding
I didn't like what their mezzo beans
were doing so I bought on the army then
I didn't know how to get to Spain till
one day I was going to work and in
Hollywood as a dishwasher in the
Hollywood Roosevelt Hotel and I see you
on the side of a building
friends Abraham Lincoln Brigade I turned
the corner went up there oh I want to go
to Spain what was the Abraham Lincoln
Brigade and why was it named after
Abraham Lincoln okay
it was it came to be the name it was not
an official name at that time but in
later years it has been used as the name
to cover all of these Americans who
volunteered to fight in Spain
at the time the the first American
all-american unit there was called the
Abraham Lincoln battalion then there was
a George Washington battalion then the
two of them were merged and they became
Lincoln Washington battalion then there
was another battalion that had the name
of some Canadian Patriots but actually
was mostly Americans it was also an
American medical unit but the veterans
of all of these things began as soon as
I get back to the United States calling
themselves veterans of the Abraham
Lincoln Brigade because it was just
simpler and that's how people have
referred to them ever since so when we
speak of these 2800 Americans who went
to Spain including del Berg who is the
last known survivor of the group they
were the participants in the Abraham
Lincoln Brigade when did you start your
research on this book well I certainly
started being interested in the subject
many many years ago one of my first Jobs
was as a daily newspaper reporter at the
San Francisco Chronicle in the 1960s and
as it happened to other reporters at the
newspaper both of them 30 or 40 years
older than me were veterans of the
Abraham Lincoln Brigade and when things
were slow in the the newsroom I used to
ask them about their experiences in
Spain and got fascinated by it
over the next couple of decades I met
other Lincoln veterans and actually was
good friends with two more for many many
years in the San Francisco Bay Area
where I live so I've been fascinated by
their experiences for a long time in the
way that when you know somebody who's
personally lived through something it
brings you closer to that piece of
history at the same time one of my
favorite writers of all time is George
Orwell and I early on read his wonderful
wonderful memoir of fighting in Spain
homage to Catalonia
which gives a somewhat different picture
of this conflict than you'll hear from
Lincoln brigade veterans what's the
difference the difference is that Orwell
did not fight with the group of
international volunteers that the
Lincoln's were part of which was
basically these these 35 40,000 foreign
volunteers that I mentioned they were
organized by the world's communist
parties Orwell had a very independent
streak went to Spain intending to
probably join this force that the
communist parties were organizing got
there and then discovered that a
political party in Spain that he felt
much closer to that was a a sister party
to the Independent Labour Party in
Britain that he was affiliated with had
its own militia and so he joined its
militia at the at the front and there
was great factional feuding among these
different parts of the the Spanish
Republic so Orwell has a somewhat
different picture of the war although I
think he too felt he was fighting in a
good cause and he wished they had won as
you say in your book he was six feet
three here's some it's not video of
George Orwell but it's a man reading
they have part of the home ejector
Catalonia Catalonia is where Catalonia
is in the northeast corner of Spain the
upper right hand corner as you look at
the map and what's the biggest city in
Barcelona and what is why is that
relevant to the book end to the war well
it's where Orwell Orwell was fighting in
Catalonia and Aragon which is the the
region right next to it and Catalonia
especially is a part of Spain we've
heard a lot about in recent years
because it's a strong separatist
movement there they speak a different
language Catalan there and people who've
lived there and fought there get very
attached to this region as Orwell was in
this video this reading you can watch
when they get to the picture of some of
the fighters there George Orwell stick
so because of his height plus watches
Berman claims straight from England the
aspect of Barcelona was something starts
him from overwhelming it was the first
time that I've ever been in a town with
a working class within the saddle
practically every building of any size
had been seized by the workers who was
draped with red flag or with the red and
black flag of the anarchist
every war would scroll with a hammer and
sickle and with the initials of the
Revolutionary Party every shop and cafe
had an inscription saying it had been
selected by everyone called everyone
else comrade and that and said salud
instead of one I fear all this was queer
and moving it was much in it I did not
understand in some way I did not even
like it but I recognized it immediately
as a state of affairs worth fighting for
obviously the man at the back in talking
about comrades and the hammer and sickle
and all that and you write about a lot
of Americans were there that consider
themselves communist at the time what
was their interest in communism well
let's talk about that but I also want to
come back to Orwell's description of
revolutionary Barcelona because it was a
special thing there here's what I think
was going on Brian when we look at the
world as it was in the mid 1930s it was
a pretty grim place here in the United
States close to a quarter of the working
population was without jobs there were
thirty four million Americans living in
households with no cash income huge
encampments of homeless and jobless
people everywhere you look in Central
Park in New York near Wall Street in New
York every American city had these
Hooverville shanty towns as they were
called it was very easy for people to
believe that capitalism had failed it
was also very easy to believe that there
was an alternative system communism in
the Soviet Union which one didn't hear
much bad news
about whatever problems the Soviet Union
had certainly unemployment didn't seem
to be one of them and you know we always
want to idealize some distant place that
seems to offer a happy alternative to
our own misery in one way or another and
so millions of people all over the world
without knowing much about what was
really happening in the Soviet Union
became true believing communists
something that reinforced that feeling I
think was that when the war in Spain
broke out none of the major Western
democracies Britain France or the United
States would provide any help through
the Spanish Republic which none of them
would even sell it arms and Republican
Spain had the money to buy arms the only
country major country that was willing
to sell them anything was Joseph
Stalin's Soviet Union people didn't
realize at that time that he was asking
for some things in return namely top
positions for Spanish and Soviet
communists in the Spanish Republic's
army and security apparatus but it was
clearly the only major country that was
providing any help to Spain and indeed a
General Franco and his Nationalists
would have won the Civil War much sooner
if Stalin had not done this they would
have overrun Madrid in late 1936 and the
war would have been over in a matter of
weeks or months after that so this was
certainly one thing that drew people to
communism and made people appreciate
what Stalin appeared to be doing for
Spain but there was something else going
on which got almost ignored by the press
at that time and it's one of the things
that makes this war so fiendishly
complicated but also to me deeply
fascinating and here's what it was and
Orwell referred to it when he was
talking about the spirit and parcel
in Catalonia and Spain x' north-east and
other pockets of the country as well
Franco's nationalists were defeated in
their initial attempt to take over not
by loyal army soldiers because most army
officers had gone over to his side but
by badly trained hastily organized
militia units put together by left-wing
political parties and trade unions they
were the ones who beat back the coup
attempt in Barcelona and other cities
and when that happened these workers
militias found themselves essentially
controlling a sizeable chunk of Spain
and during that time this is beginning
late July 1936 they put into effect in
parts of the country the most
far-reaching social revolution Western
Europe had ever seen workers took over
factories landless peasants took over
these huge estates where they had worked
as laborers waiters took over
restaurants trolley car drivers and a
railway bear women took over the
transportation system you see people
driving railway locomotives with the
Union initials on the side at
Barcelona's Hotel Ritz waiters and
Busboys took over the dining room and
turned it into people's cafeteria number
one for the poor it was an amazing
amazing spectacle Orwell saw it and was
fascinated by it the government of the
Spanish Republic was appalled that this
was happening because they suspected
quite correctly that if Spain Republican
Spain were perceived as a revolutionary
society it meant they would never have a
chance to buy arms from the US Britain
and France as it happened US Britain and
France never sold them arms anyway the
foreign correspondents who flocked from
all over the world and huge numbers to
cover the war in Spain
largely ignored the social revolution
there very few stories about it because
they were all competing with each other
to cover the battle for madrid city was
under siege the hotel where they were
living was being bombed this to them
seemed the big story but I was
fascinated by the Spanish revolution
could find very very little coverage of
it by any of the American correspondents
and then discovered that the most
extensive record of what it felt like as
a foreigner to live through that amazing
revolutionary period was in a series of
letters in an unpublished manuscript
written by a nineteen year old American
woman who lived through that period and
she was sort of my favorite find in
terms of a character for this book Louis
or Louis or and who was she
Louis or was a student at the University
of Louisville in Kentucky and in the
spring of 1936 she had married an
economics instructor at the University
who was a bit older than she and the two
of them went to Europe on their
honeymoon and they visited France in
Germany and while there they heard news
that there had been this coup attempt in
in Spain but that in part of the country
there was this extraordinary social
revolution the ores were leftists but of
a very independence or very
anti-stalinist they were fascinated by
the idea that here was a revolution that
seemed to be bubbling from the bottom up
and not top down imposed by a single
party luck had happened in the Soviet
Union and Louis said to her somewhat
older somewhat stodgy her husband we
have to go there she insisted the two of
them hitchhiked to the Spanish border
and crossed over two months after the
coup began and lived for ten months in
revolutionary Barcelona got jobs quickly
and Louis wrote the most extraordinary
series of letters home
during this this period where did you
find them they the letters have been
published in a small book that is
printed only in a small Edition only in
England it's never been reviewed in a
single US newspaper or magazine that's
where some of what she has to say is and
the other stuff she she has to say is in
a memoir that she spent most of the
remainder of her life writing and
rewriting and rewriting never found a
publisher for and there are copies of it
in various archives and I got in touch
with her daughter who was very helpful
to me and made me made me copies of it
and it's an extraordinary voice here is
this nineteen year old American never
been out of the United States before
suddenly finds herself in the midst of
this extraordinary social revolution in
a country whose language she can't speak
there are very few Americans after all
who speak Catalan but she's fascinated
by it and has a kind of sweeping
enthusiasm that I think only an upper
middle class person can have for a
workers revolution because it's a sort
of a chance for her to identify with the
working class but she gives a
wonderfully vivid picture of what it was
like to live in Barcelona in that in
that period where did she go after those
ten months at the end of that time the
conflict which I referred to before
between the Spanish Republic's
government and these revolutionaries
sort of came to a head because both the
Spanish communists and the more
mainstream parties of the Spanish
Republic did not want a social
revolution going on while they were
trying to fight this war they did not
want to have all these independent
militias responsible to different
political parties at the front they
wanted a unified army under a central
command which was not an unsensible
thing to want
if you're trying to win a war against an
army backed by Hitler and Mussolini and
essentially the Revolution was
suppressed there was some
street-fighting foreign supporters like
Louis or and her husband Charles were
arrested they were let go after about
ten days and forced to leave the country
where'd they go
they lived in Paris for a couple of
months then returned to the United
States remained active in progressive
politics divorced after a few years and
but for Louis particularly this period
in Barcelona remained a high point of
her life for the rest of her days you
can go on YouTube and see several
versions it's the same film of a film
called the Spanish earth and this is
just a 42 second excerpt from it and the
narrator is a man named Ernest Hemingway
which in itself was controversial well
let's run it and then you can explain
how this movie fit into the whole
discussion back through 36 through 39
living in the cellars of that ruined
building of the enemy they are Moors and
civil gods they're brave troops or they
would not have held out after their
position is hopeless but they are
professional soldiers fighting against
the people in arms trying to impose the
will of the military and the will of the
people and the people hate them for
without their tenacity and the constant
aid of Italy in Germany the Spanish
revolt would have ended six weeks after
it began there's a lot to talk about
here but start with Moors who were the
Moors who were they fighting for Spain
had a colony or Protectorate as it was
called Spanish Morocco which is
basically the northern slice along the
Mediterranean of what today is Morocco
and there had been a series of colonial
revolts there during the 1920s and
earlier on the Spanish army had been
much occupied in suppressing these
revolts and they had done so by
recruiting indigenous troops mercenaries
from among the Arab and Berber
population of the the region and in
Spanish these were known as morose or
Moors and they were the most effective
fighting force at the command of Franco
and the nationalist generals because
they had been fighting these colonial
wars for some some years and with the
aid of transport aircraft swiftly sent
by Hitler the Moors were transported
from Africa to Spain at the beginning of
the nationalist coup attempt and and
served really in the brunt of the
of the attack that then took place with
the Moors Muslims yes because the reason
I ask that is you have a discussion in
the book about how Franco provided women
for these the Moors and that seems not
to track with what the Muslims would do
under their religion and also is there
any relationship to what we're saying
today in the world about you know that
between the ISIS and the Muslims and but
what we're watching well unfortunately
organized encouraged mass rape has been
a part of many wars in many many times
there sometimes when we hear about it
and have eyewitness accounts there
sometimes when it's happened on a wide
scale and we don't have those accounts
because nobody was nobody was recording
them but one of the times when it did
happen on a wide scale was in the
Spanish Civil War and I think by
encouraging the Moorish troops to do the
raping which the Nationalists did in a
widespread and very well-documented way
they were playing on centuries of racial
fears in Spain you know you're gonna be
raped by an Arab and indeed there was
one American correspondent who was on
the scene who recorded debates in
nationalist army officers messes among
officers saying you know well these
women who are being raped you know they
are communists but they're still Spanish
women no is this really a proper thing
to do
yes or no but it went on and it went on
on a huge scale the Catholic Church know
this was going on and did they continue
to support Franco oh absolutely
absolutely
they supported Franco so much that you
can see photographs of catholic bishops
and Archbishop's and even a cardinal and
one of them raising their hands in the
fascist salute side by side with Franco
and his generals and they knew all this
raping was going on
sure-sure back to that clip for a second
ernest hemingway what role would this
movie play who was responsible for and
why was he narrating today Hemingway of
course had been very involved with Spain
the novel that first really brought him
to the world's attention the Sun Also
Rises was based on a trip to Spain in
the 1920s he felt a great almost
proprietary love for the country and
even though he was in some ways one of
the most unpolitical of American writers
he never even voted in the election of
1936 for instance he felt a great sense
of outrage at the nationalist coup in
Spain as if a country that he really
loved was having great violence done to
it and he did everything he could to
attract retention and support for the
cause of the Spanish Republic he
combined that with becoming a reporter
again he'd been a foreign correspondent
in Europe for a time in the 1920s signed
up to write a long series of pieces from
Spain for the North American newspaper
Alliance which was a syndicate of some
50 papers and made for long trips to
Spain during the war to write these
pieces he also was fascinated by the new
medium of film and felt that you know a
documentary film might help reach a
wider audience so he and a film crew put
together this documentary called the
Spanish earth and you hear his voice
narrating in that clip that we watched
originally Orson Welles was signed up to
be the narrator but somehow or other he
and Hemingway got into a terrible fight
when the
in the production room of the film one
was being put together let me interrupt
just what a show
Arsenal I was talking about this and you
can further explain we met in the
projection of a movie which he had made
and which he wanted me to narrate and he
had written the commentary this is many
years ago and we haven't seen each other
this is a dark projection room when I
was reading the text and I said is it
really necessary to say this do you
think wouldn't be better just see the
picture and things like that and then I
heard this growl from the darkness you
know I'm damn [ __ ] who runs an art
theater tried to tell me how to write
the narration and so on so I began to
camp it up I thought if that's what I'm
doing when I said Oh miss deadening what
you think because you're so big and
strong and have hair on your chest you
see so this great figure stood up and
swung at me so I swung at him now you
have the picture of the Spanish Civil
War being projected on a screen and
these two heavy figures swinging away at
each other and missing most of that
that's an interview with Michael
Parkinson back in 1971 with Orson Welles
put put the pieces together well and the
movie itself and why they made it
Hemingway did have this tendency to get
into fights with people all the time so
after this one with Welles he took over
the narration and the film was it was
finally released has Hemingway's voice
it's a documentary that has some
extraordinary footage in it it was shown
around the United States at the time it
did not reach the vast audience that
Hemingway hoped it would and it was not
enough to shock the United States out of
the widespread feeling that the US
should stay out of any European war at
the same time that Hemingway was in
Spain he was married for the second time
but he started a liaison as you say with
Martha Gellhorn
I want to show you some Martha Gellhorn
for this is back in 1983 and then fit
these pieces together there was a
definite enemy hmm and and a definite
enemies that all of us kept saying if
you don't stop it here there will be the
war in Europe and we were regarded as
either casandra's of fellow travelers or
whatever they called us at that time and
then of course lo and behold it came
about who was Martha Gellhorn
she was a young journalist and it's
believed Hemingway began his affair with
her just before they went to Spain
together but she returned with him on
all of these trips he made to Spain and
they were sort of the social center of
this group of foreign correspondents in
Madrid she wrote for the magazine
Colliers which had a huge audience in
the United States at that time and she
was as equally a passionate partisan of
the Spanish Republic as Hemingway was
Martha Gellhorn had a connection that
Hemingway hoped would be valuable which
was that Eleanor Roosevelt was a close
friend of Gellhorn's mother and the
Roosevelts who had this extraordinary
habit of asking all sorts of interesting
people to come and live with them at the
White House for a time had actually a
couple of years previously invited
Martha Gellhorn to come and live with
them while she worked on her writing but
Gellhorn soon found that Eleanor really
wanted her help answering this vast
correspondence as Eleanor got letters
from people all over the country by the
thousands every day asking her help with
one thing and another
so Gellhorn didn't last there very long
but she retained this very close
relationship with Eleanor Roosevelt and
continued to write her letters from
Spain while she and Hemingway were there
and after they returned and they
actually went Martha Gellhorn Ernest
Hemingway and showed the film for the
first time
to the Roosevelts in the white house in
mid 1937 it's certainly the most
exclusive audience for a film premiere
that one can think of they hoped that
this would stir at least President
Roosevelt if not the American people out
of the stance of neutrality towards the
Spanish Civil War but they didn't
succeed and we we as a country at an
embargo against selling arms to the
Republicans over there and that's not
the party but the people that were in
power at the time and and it was that
ever close to being broken where we
would sell arms well it was broken in a
very crucial way and here's what it was
there was a series of different laws
having to do with neutrality legislative
neutrality American neutrality the gist
of which that were there was a
Neutrality Act and then it was amended
and there were various things tech dog
act on the gist of it was you could not
sell arms to any country engaged at war
or to either side in a civil war there
were also further restrictions on things
that weren't arms peculiarly something
that wasn't regarded as a military arms
arms in any way was oil but of course
modern armies run on oil and 60% of the
oil going to both sides in Spain during
the war went directly to the armies you
know you need it for trucks tanks
aircraft self-propelled artillery
anything else you can you can think of
you know moving tens of thousands of
soldiers one place or another this was
not classified as armament but the law
said very strictly that it couldn't
travel the oil couldn't travel on
American ships and moreover it couldn't
be sold on credit now all of these
foreign correspondents in Madrid never
asked questions about this here there
were being bombed by Hitler's bomb
in the skies over the city they never
looked up and asked whose fuel is
powering those aircraft it should have
been an obvious question they knew this
about what American neutrality
legislation there was was they knew that
the nationalist Spain had no oil tankers
to transport oil there even if they
could buy it legally they knew also
nationalist Spain was very short of cash
and so any oil sold to them would have
had to be on credit
they knew that Hitler and Mussolini who
were supporting the nationalist Spanish
coup attempt were oil importers and not
exporters it would have been difficult
and expensive for them to supply Franco
with the oil where was it coming from
well it was coming from Texas and it was
coming in violation of American law the
head of Texaco one of the major US oil
companies at the time was a man named
tor killed Reber who was basically a
fascist sympathizer he had great
affection for right-wing dictators not
just Francisco Franco but other
dictators at other times in other parts
of the world including Hitler and
Germany a few years later he happily
supplied Franco and his Nationalists
with most of their oil he shipped it
there in Texaco tankers violating US law
by doing so the tankers would leave the
Texaco pipeline terminal at Port Arthur
Texas ostensibly bound for Rotterdam or
Amsterdam or Antwerp their captains
would open sealed orders at sea
redirecting them to ports and
nationalist Spain he supplied Franco
with all of this oil on credit violating
US law in another way and he supplied
Franco with the oil at a huge discount
something that he never told Texaco
shareholders about or as far as we can
tell from consulting the minutes of
their meetings he never told his own
board of directors about it
he did something else as well which has
only come to light in recent years
through the investigations of a Spanish
scholar who very generously shared his
documents with me
Texaco being a multinational oil company
had imports all over the world offices
tank farms installations agents insurers
you know huge network of people and
imports everywhere Reber sent out
instructions to all these folks saying
keep your eyes out for any information
about oil shipments going to the spanish
republic and send us any data you have
this information was passed on to
nationalists spain's high command for
the use of nationalist bomber pilots and
submarine captains looking for targets
because the lifeline of oil going to the
spanish republic was of course
profoundly necessary for it to be able
to fight this war 29 oil tankers heading
for the spanish republic during the
course of the war were sunk captured or
damaged and in one or two cases we can
tie that directly to information
supplied by Texaco so the US might be
neutral but Texaco had gone to war you
mentioned that there this American
running Texaco was Pro Franco
pro-fascist here's another commentator
that was accused of being Pro Franco
pro-fascist and people our age will
remember Fuller's junior was on mutual
broadcasting this is only a 40 seconds
let's watch him go Spain very
interesting character we want no
dictators here I do think that he has
however done great here for Spain
Time magazine March 21st 1955 quote
among the total Franco's journalistic
Myra's few have been medicated than
seven Lewis Junior
Lewis has repeatedly charged that
criticism to Franco's dictatorship came
from net livers and pickles input I
cannot be responsible Mike for what Time
magazine they may or may not print it
was 1958 Mike Wallace what can you tell
us about the the discussion going on in
this country about Pro Franco
anti-franco well I think there probably
a lot of people who felt as Fulton Lewis
jr. said there that well Franco was a
dictator but as long as he was a
anti-communist dictator that was the
important thing we don't want dictators
here but dictators okay for another
place and if they keep the Communists
out many people felt that there was an
enormous Lee strong feeling among the
right-wing here at that time that
because the military helped that the
Spanish Republic was getting came from
the Soviet Union that if the Republic
won the war Soviet influence would be
greatly enhanced and it might even
become a Soviet satellite I don't think
that would have happened but it was
certainly a fear that was whipped up
very effectively how many people died in
the war about two hundred thousand were
killed in combat at least 200,000 more
were killed in political murders that
happened during the war itself about
three-quarters of them were supporters
of the Spanish Republic or presumed
supporters of the Republic who were
murdered by the Spanish nationalists as
they progressively took over parts of
the country about a quarter of them were
supporters or presumed supporters of the
Nationalists who were killed by mobs in
Republican territory it was a very very
brutal period of time
especially at the beginning and the open
opening months of the war where people
of these opposing politics just felt it
was legitimate to slaughter anybody who
had the opposite point of view how many
of the 2800 Americans had fought there
between 36 and 39 were killed about 750
and the majority of the remainder were
wounded this for you is what book
this is my eighth book what's which one
was the big seller probably that would
be book number five King Leopold's ghost
which is about the Belgian colonial
conquest of the Congo
I read that is back in 1999 98 and then
you had to NL Wars there years to the
1914 to 1918 and 2012 and then several
others as you say it's your eighth book
you grew up and born in New York
graduate of Harvard in 1963 you'll now
live in San Francisco Berkeley Berkeley
you teach anymore I do I teach a class
at the Graduate School of Journalism UC
Berkeley why did you start as one of the
founders the magazine Mother Jones and
who was Mother Jones okay
mother Jones was a great 19th and early
20th century American labor heroine who
battled for the rights of workers and
many strikes in that period and unlike
far too many people in the history of
the American left she had a great sense
of humor so when a group of us were
looking around in the early 1970s for
somebody to name a magazine after we
picked her name I had started as I think
I mentioned earlier as a newspaper
reporter in San Francisco then I'd
worked for another magazine called
ramparts which is published no more but
existed at that time but I've always
been sort of half journalist and half
activist because I am very much a child
of the 1960s when I got out of college
the civil rights movement was
the anti-war movement was on my then
girlfriend now wife and I were briefly
civil rights workers in Mississippi in
the summer of 1964 the year that a
thousand people went down there from the
north I was very much involved in the
movement against the Vietnam War so for
me I've always been drawn to writing
about people who have been active in one
way or another in trying to change the
world I can't say that I've succeeded in
changing the world myself and to tell
the truth it's a lot easier to write
about people who are doing that than to
go out there and actually try to change
it but I continue to admire people who
are trying to change the world I don't
know if you've ever seen this but it's
fun to watch thirty Seconds 1930 Mother
Jones was a hundred years old and here
she is
[Music]
Riesling from Cork County County Cork in
Ireland is Mother Jones today making
money or is it supposed to make money
mio
it's a non-profit institution it raises
a lot of money from generous donors and
readers tens of thousands of them each
year but I'm very pleased that it's
still publishing I think it's had
considerable impact you may remember in
the 2012 election the story of Mitt
Romney's 47% speech which some people
think cost him the election that
revelation was a Mother Jones story I'm
proud to be associated with the magazine
still I haven't I can't claim to have
done much work there over the last 35
years but I'm still on the board of
directors so what about your own
politics over the years where would you
put yourself today I would say an
independent utopian I still think we
need to find ways of getting to a much
better much different world than the one
we're in today if there was an
International Brigade of volunteers to
join today I would say it's people who
are fighting against climate change that
to me seems the overwhelming issue
facing us on this planet right now and I
just heartily endorse any efforts we can
do to make that far more front and
center in our politics than it is right
now when you went to Mississippi you
were in your early 20s
obviously demonstrating against Vietnam
you weren't much older than that what
was the average age of the American of
the Abraham Lincoln brigade Americans
fighting in Spain in 1936 three
seriously it was a little bit older than
that it was about 28 there there were
some students people who had dropped out
of college to go in fact one of the
people I talked about and in Spain in
our hearts is a guy who was a senior
it's worth more college and ran away to
fight in Spain and was fatally wounded
he was actually the first American
casualty his name Joe Seligman jr. and
yeah there's a picture in your book
meeting with his sister meeting with the
sister yeah his sister who's still very
much alive 95 years old a wonderful
woman but he was and so he was only 20
or 21 when he was killed
most volunteers were older as I say the
average age was about 28 many of them
were people who were unemployed dock
workers longshoremen clothing workers
because there were strikes in those
industries in New York City where a
great many of the volunteers came from
so they tended to be a little older than
the early 20s activists that we were
talking about we're out of time but the
one thing we haven't got there a lot
there's a lot more in your book about a
lot more Americans the stories of people
that fought in Spain the name of the
book is Spain in our hearts it's a story
about the Spanish Civil War 1936 to 1939
that Francisco Franco won and our guest
has been Adam hope she'll thank you very
much for joining us thank you bro
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts if you liked this Q&A
interview then here are some other